what was your childhood dream
that's a big question what was my
childhood dream
my childhood dream was
to be a writer but
you know as you grow up you realize well
you're not gonna make any money of that
or you're gonna end up in some city
living in some derelict apartment with a
hot plate
alcoholic something terrible you know
how many of them have
horrible endings and then i thought well
that can't be me
i better go get a real degree and and
forget being a writer
so i pushed it away where do you think
that stereotype comes from
i although they're it is true and some
of those who you know charles bukowski
ended up actually having a career even
though
and he wrote about sort of that derelict
sort of writer existence and then
transcended it and where do you think it
comes from
that's a very big question but
i think that there's a level of
romanticism to say that you've overcome
the odds or that you've
you know you've either dried up and look
see i told you you shouldn't do that or
it
really it's the narrative that you that
really resonates with you
right do you have fear or do you have
joy and belief that things are going to
really turn out
and at that moment i had fear right like
well how special am i i'm not right
and so you can look at that narrative
and say oh well
that's what happens to people who write
they drink or you can be bukowski
who works at the post office and toils
away
all the time when it's free moments and
actually turns
the living in a in a room with a hot
plate
and drinking a lot at the bar into a
whole
you know body of work it's really how
you approach life i think it's a good
metaphor for that
did you try to pursue your dream as a
writer
or did you just let it fade away and say
not for me i let it fade away i let the
dream of writing
fade away it was always there i didn't
let it go too it was kind of like a crab
doing a crab walk
and it was sort of always walking
parallel to me
and i would dabble it in it in other
ways
i had been a spokesperson and
i represented major corporations on
television so i did it very stealth-like
right
i had i would do makeovers for tv this
is sally before
and this is sally after and i would
write all the copy that when i sat down
and spoke with the hosts and drove the
segment
and i had a lot of fun writing for that
and then also writing for
i worked as a journalist for
entertainment television
cnn is where i started in the san
francisco bureau
and then hbo entertainment news so i
learned a lot about
story in those places but i didn't fully
embrace
it didn't resonate with me i wanted to
write but it wasn't what i wanted to
write i didn't know what i wanted to
write
so i didn't have a voice yet
when did you decide you wanted to be a
filmmaker well
i never fully embraced being a filmmaker
either
right so i had done i'd learned a lot
about
video and and you know as technology
became more accessible for the home
market i just jumped in
and learned how to shoot and edit myself
at home
so i could do a lot and bring that
to the work world i worked a lot with
corporations and so i
shot and produced and direct a lot of
videos for
the corporate world and also for some
for the non-profit world
but as as being a
a fully fledged filmmaker i never was
i always sort of worked in different
ways as a producer
as a as all the smaller jobs
so yeah not really fully owning it but
you did some
corporate videos where i think you
didn't you do one with tiger woods and
i did different people okay i did do a
video that was actually shot on
film oh yeah so that was right as
digital was taking over
and i uh i directed that
and had a dp uh who was a friend of mine
and that was phenomenal so shooting
getting to shoot all different types of
people and tiger woods was one of those
was a really terrific experience to be
able to go in
shoot it and then go and sit and post
and and edit it with an editor
so yes i did a lot of that industrial
type
videos for corporations and that was for
nike
but then there was something in you and
maybe i'm jumping ahead to your story
that
you didn't feel satisfied in your job or
you started to question things
in terms of well did
did did you enjoy what you were doing
because i know that you had sort of a
moment where you reevaluated everything
you talked about it in your
your ted talk right wow
so i had you know i'd started my career
as a journalist
and then from there i became a
spokesperson and so that's where i
i talked i did these makeovers for
television and
you know everything that i did i was
sort of searching
and it was always in the communication
realm but i was never feeling
fully satisfied and gratified right so
i ended up somebody said to me
i started laughing when she said it to
me because i had worked with her and i
had shot the videos it was for nike and
she said to me you could produce these
large-scale live events
and i said what how awful i see you up
until three in the morning on those
budgets
and then i ended up doing it right and i
did it for quite a few years
and again i hit a wall at one point but
at the same time that i hit the wall
actually i'd hit the wall a little bit
early er than that
the bottom fell out of the market when
the great recession hit
and so that would force my hand to say
okay
what do i want to do because the first
thing that they do is slash
these budgets um for these live events
that corporations do
because they're expensive you know they
can be hundreds of thousands and
sometimes
millions of dollars and so
um there i was without a job and i said
you know what i always want to be a
writer
and that's what i'm gonna do where do i
start and i thought well the
entrepreneurial world looks really
interesting and so i had just gotten
married
and we moved to orange county and
i was a stranger in a strange land
because from west hollywood to
you know the laguna area is like night
and day like where
am i who are these people my husband
used to say don't say that
you know i feel like i don't know yeah
that's along yeah like
oh it's a fish out of water and
so i marched immediately there was
there was this fast pitch event that
this group called the
coast angels put on and it was a group
of high net worth individuals
who actually put in their own money into
these early stage startups
you got better at odds at vegas of
getting a return
by the way so they were really
passionate many of them had been
um had their own startups and had
successful exits
so i didn't know anything about the
startup world but i thought i went and i
watched this competition
and i thought boy i could help clarify
these folks
telling their stories and i had before
that toward the end of my career i
started
helping people on stage the the
corporate people right the
the vps and stuff feeling more
comfortable on stage so i had a sense of
story
so when i started working with these
folks um
these are these entrepreneurs and
crafting their story i actually just
went up to the
the tech coast angels president said i
can help and he's like you can
and i was like yeah okay come on and
that's where i really learned about
first of all the startup world
all of the language and then how to tell
a great story in 60 seconds or 90
seconds
and it's the same kind of model or a
very similar model
to what i use for speech writing or for
especially for pitches when in the
startup world when they have to pitch
to investors like 10 minute pitches so
it taught me a lot about
the economy of words and weighing and
measuring
every single word because it matters our
words
matter and were these um
little stories of these these 60 to 90
uh i'm sorry
what was the exact time frame the ones
that i ended up
working on were 90 seconds so they gave
us 90 seconds
90 seconds were they about the company
or the
the individual speaking so they were
really
about the company so
they what the market was that they plan
to go in what the unmet need was so
there's a formula to
how i really learned to create a formula
so they could follow the speakers could
then
go oh i get that and it's complicated
they had to learn because they were
it's an organic process right where they
start in the startup
is not where they end up it's constantly
iterating and
so they had to
learn to get the touch points as so did
i the touch points that the audience
wanted to hear
and i would tease the entrepreneur i'd
say okay the whole goal
this is where it's pavlov's dog we need
to hit all the right bell notes
so they'll salivate at the end right and
that's essentially what we were doing we
would start with a problem
we'd go into the solution we'd hit the
marketing points that they wanted to
hear
we talk about their team and then we
close it with a tagline
in 90 seconds it was amazing how much
territory we could cover
what were the biggest challenges you
faced in moving forward in your new
career
doing this script writing and helping
people hone their own pitch and story
the biggest challenges i faced i'd
already been working with people a lot
but never on such
an intimate basis and so i would work
when i would work with entrepreneurs i'd
often work with teams of eight to twelve
people
and all different personalities many of
them phd's me
or or lawyers or are you know
a lot of education and
probably i had the
the best gift was learning about my own
ego and when they
really irritated me like how do i manage
that
hopefully i'm not showing the smoke
that's coming out of my ears right now
you know because sometimes
and after time i i got to learn that not
to take it so personally
what i what i learned is that probably
what i do working with speakers whether
they're entrepreneurs
or their speakers that hit the stage i'm
managing
50 percent of what i do is managing fear
there's a lot of fear because it's ego
based
right and so my goal is for for whoever
hits the stage or stands up in front of
an audience of one or one thousand
or ten thousand um
is to cut through that ego and to really
step
forward and and have a north star that
matters to keep you on
course because whether you're pitching
or you're telling a story
um on the stage it isn't about you
you're just the messenger
what does that fear sound like when you
hear somebody say something how do you
know oh
okay that's fear talking right now fear
usually comes off it can come off in so
many different ways right
it it can be dismissive it can
be rude it can be abrupt
uh know it all a lot of know it and
by the way everything i'm saying the
universe sent me these people
to learn because i've suffered from all
of this
in my in my career in my life right and
so my speakers have taught me a lot
about me
because um i've
i've had these same things what are you
going to tell me i know all this
right and so
also too sometimes they think
people are confused when they hear that
a
speechwriter is coming in because they
hear speaker coach
and for a lot of people with education
they find speaker coaching trivial
and unimportant and many of them have
lectured around the world or have stud
stood up in front of juries so they find
it kind of ridiculous that i would come
in and
work with them but once they start to
understand i'm i'm really there to work
on the foundation which is story
and that without them opening up to be
more transparent and less defensive
um because defense being defensive is
really
think of the yin yang right dark and
light
when you see somebody who's defensive or
brash or harsh in any way they're really
they have a soft center
and they're hiding that that fragility
and
you know that they that's what they use
to protect themselves so whenever you
see that
never take it personally because it
really isn't about you and that that's
what my speakers have taught me
over the years probably one of the most
valuable lessons
and so you know pretty much the majority
of the speakers i've worked with
i've gotten over the finish line to
varying degrees i've had a couple that i
couldn't
they just were not emotionally available
and they just
quit so that does happen as well
and i push my speakers so i'm not mean
but i'm firm sure there's a difference
and
did you always have a high emotional iq
or did that come
because you know some people seems like
they're almost born with it or or did it
take
time where you dealt with these speakers
and they showed you things and
you showed them and it's just sort of
this simpatico thing
yeah i think i was always somebody who
could feel a room
but being able to sit back and feel a
room it's
very different than sitting with
that room and
reaching beneath the words going beneath
to the meaning beneath the words
and letting those other people know it's
okay to have those feelings
i didn't know how to do that you know
when i opened up my toolbox from a
communication tool
toolbox i would have told you before i
am so capable
but then i looked in the toolbox when it
really came time to work with people and
i was like i just have a screwdriver
apparently i've been turning around and
using the handle
and hammer things in so
essentially what the speakers brought to
me
is having to exercise that and to
to be able to start to hear the feelings
that they have beneath the words
so most of the time when we communicate
we talk on the surface
right but if we really listen to what
people are saying they're saying
something deeper i'm afraid
i'm lonely i'm sad but
rarely do you hear that in communication
right
and so when i can sit with my speakers
that many of my speakers say to me
oh my gosh you're like a life coach and
i'm like i don't know what that is
but i'm gonna take it as a compliment
um because i'm not there to judge i'm
there to hear and i have to hear i hear
you know a lot hours i'll sit with my
speakers and i will hear their life
stories
and then it just i'll filter it
over time to let the best of their
stories
rise to the top doesn't mean that we
won't put in
unflattering moments but i'm there to
guide their stories in a way
that the audience can really feel and
that will really resonate with them
so what are some of the questions that
you begin asking someone let's suppose
i contact you and say i would like you
to help me
you know i'm a screenwriter or even an
actor filmmaker and i want to
hone my own personal story and i've
already talked about my projects
but when people ask me what do you do
and who are you
how do i hone my you know what's our
first sort of meeting like
just 30 minutes of sitting down and just
having a conversation so i can start to
most of the people that come to me
you're very specific in the question
but most of the people that come to me
are not they think they want one thing
but they really want something totally
different so
i ask my my speakers i say you know do
me a favor write down what you think you
want
and here's how many words you get and
then
yeah and i usually give them like 30
more
and then we carve it back and what
usually the first draft that i see
will never look anything like the final
draft
and i have people write it out because
there's something special that happens
when you take time to write it out
especially
and then we work on the conversational
tone of it right so i can get to know
you
that's why so many hours of conversation
and to really hear what's in your heart
because most of us don't know what's in
our heart
part of the problem i see with the
speakers that come to me
i've worked with everybody with a high
school diploma to
like you know i said phds and beyond
right
and the minute you have
five minutes of education
you begin to move in the world
in with a logic based mind
and so that's not great for storytelling
that's really kind of awful
you so i begin to tell my speakers i
just worked with somebody who
who made it to the finals of the rhodes
scholar
interviews and so when he and i sat down
and we were talking about it
i said well
one of the illnesses of education is
they reward the mind and in storytelling
it's the heart and so you want to look
at
your vehicle as your heart
and the steering wheel as your mind
right
in story and so i said that wherever we
go
we need to be in the heart the mind
just steers us in the direction we need
to go it should help us navigate
it should help us rearrange the the
speech or the script
that is the puzzle but it's not there
because it's a feeling it's like music
if you don't hit the beats
then the audience won't feel it right
essentially
so when you sit down with someone who's
maybe very linear
and left brain and logic has guided
their whole existence
how are you kind of pulling them out of
that for a little bit because they're
going to tell you their story maybe they
do it in a chronological form
but that doesn't tell you anything about
them maybe
how are you trying to humanize them more
one of a terrific example of this is i i
worked with few years back a tedx talk
that i did
i collaborated with professor charis
kubrin
out of uci and she had a had a talk
called
has a talk called rap on trial and
when she came to me she had all of the
the touch points of what she wanted to
say
very academic right this happens it
doesn't matter
again if you have five minutes of
education or you have a phd
and so it comes in a very dry form there
were some interesting points to it but
it
wasn't a story and it wasn't even close
and so i used
the hero's journey model
and i put it on that and i followed
that story arc and once i did
you could really feel um her journey
and her struggle through the entire
story
and she was worried about it a lot of
academics it's difficult for them to
trust the process because
in the academic world if it isn't
dry and sometimes boring well then it's
not worthy
right but she was talking to a layman's
audience and so we needed to learn
and i'm that's what i tell my speakers
i'm your audience i will often refer to
we to myself as we the audience
um if i don't feel it you know then it
means that you're not feeling it
so an academic board might rejoice in
hearing certain things but
the the normal uh patron at at some
event
may not i mean there's not enough of a
personal
connection to the story let's put it
this way in academia
there's going to be one or two naysayers
that
feel like if you're not suffering then
you're not really an academic
it doesn't mean that academics don't
want great stories they do
um and they're learning now they're just
starting to make the shift
and they know the importance of it but
when
but they don't know how to get there and
they don't know how to turn
their their data into story
and that's what they do for a living and
that's also really important for them to
know
and when they talk with journalists when
they because that's the
the journalists in particular how the
the information is going to be
disseminated
so if you can't tell that story well
enough for journalists not to take it
and spin it away
and fill in the blanks you know then
you're kind of held hostage to to
how it goes downstream so so i think
it's going to be more and more important
for the academic to learn to be a better
storyteller
but that's essentially how people come
to me and it doesn't matter how much
education i'm just using that extreme
because that popped into my
into my mind my ride's here i'm sorry
that's awesome do you like rules when it
comes to
writing and telling stories are you very
much a stickler for the rules whether
it's the hero's journey
oh man rules
i know you grew up in the bay area
people in bay area like to
put myself included yeah yeah so you
know you know
yeah rules are i really fought rules
because i was like oh no i just feel
this
inherently i'm just going to put it down
because the first talks that i ever
wrote
the first speeches i ever wrote for were
for tedx orange coast
i wrote eight of them and i was like i
don't know what i'm doing
you know uh i know how to tell a story
but i didn't really know how do you get
the person's life from point a to point
b
to the end right and so i would get
halfway through the script and
by the way i had to turn around a lot of
the scripts in two to three weeks
eight of them wow so i didn't have much
time
and i was working seven days a week and
like i better figure this out oh my
goodness
right and so the rules were
i was anti-rule really and
then one day i was working on a on a
speech for this ted talk one of them and
i wanted to do this woman justice i just
adored her
her name's amy purdy and she and i were
collaborating together
and i just thought i've got to do this
justice what how do i tell a story
you know we were in there we were doing
stuff but
it just wasn't hitting the mark and so i
said okay google let's look at my
magic eight ball let me just shake it
and see what comes back
and i just typed in story arc
and all of a sudden
i clicked on images and i saw something
called the hero's journey
and i was like you know what i feel like
i've heard about that before what is
this
crazy thing called the heroes journey
and i looked at the visual it's a
beautiful visual somebody taking their
time to really show me all the steps and
i was like wait this is how i
this is how this works i can do this
this is exactly what i need
amy had eight minutes ted talks are off
in 18 minutes
but she only had eight minutes that's
what they gave her and
some of my other speakers had 12 minutes
and you know which four minutes is a
huge difference
let me tell you eight is tight and so i
was like
i can do this i can cross the threshold
with her story
this is wonderful and we did it and her
talk went viral
and so this was back in 2011 and
it was affirmation for me and i was like
i don't know these hollywood people this
way
but i love them
and so then i started following that for
certain people i started using the
hero's journey
and because there are there are
emotional beats in there
and i noticed that my speeches were
following those beats
i would just look over i'd be like is
this going the way it is
i could find it i would just mirror them
and they could almost cross map
and
what was beautiful about that is that
the the people i tend to work with the
speakers i tend to work with and
especially now
now that i've been doing this a long
time i'm really
i really want beauty out in the world
and i want my speakers to disseminate
that
that beauty which they already have in
them right
and the hero's journey really does that
because the audience
doesn't hear the speaker they hear what
the speaker has been through but they
only think about themselves and what
they've been through in relation to what
that speaker has been through
so you know speakers will be like i
don't know if i could say that and i'm
like it's not about you the audience is
gonna
say oh my god i went through that too
you know or my mother went through that
or someone i knew or
you know and they they start to they
hear your story
but in relationship to themselves and so
that
that hero's journey has been incredibly
important
um in in in the storytelling process
can you give me an example of how you
used some of the
the parts of the hero's journey to work
with amy's speech
was there like one part in particular
that you really sort of
worked on together i'm not quite sure of
amy's story forgive me maybe you can
share some of it
so amy purdy's story spoiler alert
i'm just saying okay you haven't seen
the okay the talk thank you
stop the video now go google amy purdy
ted talk
and watch it it's only eight minutes and
then come back
so essentially amy's story
is that at 19 she contracted meningitis
and she died
essentially and then was brought back
but she'd gone to the hospital
she what it does she was so advanced in
it
that the the um body tries to save the
organs and the blood rushes from it so
uh rushes from the vital organs and your
hands turn purple
her feet turn purple her cheeks and nose
and when it happens it's like frostbite
and so when they got her to the hospital
um
it was touch and go she she actually
did pass away very briefly and they
brought her back
um but it was touch and go for a long
long time
and then um in the end they had to
uh to amputate her legs from
the ankles down or the calves down
and uh both of them
and but everything else was saved i mean
she did have a lot of other
she lost hearing in her ear she had all
of these issues
so here she was this story and she'd
done a lot already at this point you
know she had been in a madonna video and
she'd done all these things
but i had to because she'd done so many
things i had to weigh and measure what
was important in the story
and that's where i had to trust my
intuition and where i could actually
look at this guide of the hero's journey
because
her life story this particular incident
fit perfectly in it so it isn't a life
story it's not an
autobiography it's a moment in time
and a great speech is it doesn't try to
cover too much it's a very narrow
subject
and this narrow subject for amy was her
life this life
where she no longer she had to let go of
the old amy
to embrace the new amy and we wrote that
in there and every time she goes
every time i say that line i cry i was
like good
yay but that was the middle part
of the hero's journey the very point
where she then
begins to embrace the journey that she's
on so even though you go over the
threshold right
you go through the steps of and i can't
remember all of them but there's that
low point in the circle right
and that's where she began to rise
like a phoenix from the ashes and she
began to
bring back what she learned of course to
cross back over
and bring the elixir back to the world
which was a speech
so it was really about her experience
and what she learned and the struggles
that she went through and how
hard it was but yet how she wouldn't
change a thing
right and so i had to figure out do we
keep the madonna video part in there
because my speakers use slides
right the majority i think i've only
worked with a couple who have not
um in high resolution photos i don't
occasionally i let them use text if it's
important to the story but
the the images are wallpaper that really
um
helps the emotion stick so the story
will be stickier
if the resolutions and the photos of the
resolution the resolution of the photos
are super emotional the photos
themselves
and she had a lot of emotional photos
and so
uh we chose the the most important parts
of the story so we had to take
them the audience low to the lowest
point to bring them back up again
in the journey where she was resurrected
and that is it was quintessential
hero's journey and i don't know who
posted that but i need to send them a
thank you note
because i just devoured that i didn't
read anything about it
i just used that chart so i'm eternally
grateful to the hero's journey joseph
campbell
and and and whoever posted that
beautiful
rendering of of the steps
so she does the ted talk and then
what's the response within what amount
of time so this is so exciting because
it's a tedx talk right so this is 2011
and and she's like okay i did the talk
it's been posted it took like a month
before they posted it great
and this was probably so we did it in
may it probably went up in june
crickets
she got about 20 000 hits and
through december and then i think it was
in december
uh all of a sudden she calls me like
completely worked up oh my god barbara
what go look at the ted talk
they had taken the tedx talk and put it
on the ted page
oh and they don't do that anymore but
they they did it for her
and so that's where you can see it is on
the ted page they
put it on the ted page
and once that happened it went viral wow
and she's like people are writing in
arabic like a month later
it just started going everywhere and we
were watching it tick through like
you know 30 thousand forty thousand
fifty thousand by the hour
and we're like oh my gosh this is so
exciting and
yeah so she just captured the hearts and
minds of so many people
her story and it's it's remarkable story
and she's a
remarkable woman just a really beautiful
on the outside but
equally as beautiful on the inside
what happens when we outgrow the story
of ourselves
you know how some people say don't get
stuck in your own story which is
actually a very powerful thing
because we can wear our stories as like
this badge to the world
whether they're good or bad what happens
when we start to outgrow
those stories i believe when you start
to outgrow your stories
you start to have like an existential
crisis
i i'm joking but that means that there's
a
there's a big shift in your life that's
happening and that's a great thing
right
did you feel that you had outgrown your
story you were a journalist
and you wanted to change it and this was
your your new
endeavor your new career with script
writing
you know i
i think that i don't know i just was
tired of what i was doing so i was
probably running from
and trying to run toward for the first
time in my life something i wanted to do
and i was too much of a chicken to be a
full rider just jump off the cliff
entirely
so i said to myself in small increments
i can learn to do these pitches
okay that's safe that's some writing and
that's some business and then i
crab walked a little bit further over
and did speech writing and then
found how rich it is and how beautiful
it is and then my next step is to go
further beyond that and i'm ready
because my speakers have given me so
much and taught me so much
but in terms of in terms of
letting go of old stories
amy's talk again is really perfect
because in that middle part
where we wrote you know i had to let go
of the old amy so i could embrace the
new
that was so profoundly powerful for her
for me for the audience for her becoming
teary
because she was literally pronouncing
that she was letting
go and you don't you would think well
you lost your legs
you move on right but loss is a tricky
thing
and loss takes time it's not when you
lose someone you love
or something you love that was you hoped
was going to be forever um
there are a lot of
little imperceptible layers that have to
be let go
and that speech for amy was a lot of
that
that she hadn't really addressed and
that's what we sat down and talked very
intimately about right um and so that's
how we got to that transition
and it was very liberating for her
and that's the power of story
when we really really start to get in
alignment
with what it is we're saying i ask my
speakers what's your motivation for
saying that i ask myself
because many times i'll throw out old
stories and i'll be like and you feel it
in your body i didn't feel right why did
i say that
that doesn't fit me anymore stop saying
that move on
right but then what
do i replace it with and what was my
motivation for saying it in
the past asking ourselves what's our
motivation
for saying anything prevents a lot of
missteps and mishaps
in the world with ourselves and with the
people around us
and that starts to get us on a better
path because our
our power is our story what are we
telling ourselves internally
externally to the world because what we
feel is what
we attract is what we are it's just a
mirror
of us right and so most of the time
we're blah blah blah blah just talking
and not understanding
that our words have weight there's a
in japanese and i'm probably going to
get it wrong but it's called i believe
it's called
kotodamo domo kotodomo i think it is
and it they say it's spirit words
that words have spirit and
they do because i've sat with those
words and i've weighed and measured them
and i can see when they hit the mark
and when people sit in the audience and
they're i can feel
them feeling the words
so as i say to my speakers
if you don't feel the words as the
speaker
the audience won't either if you think
those words
nobody cares you can't wrap your arms
around logic
you can only wrap your arms around
love and emotion that's all there is and
we're starved for it as a culture
and as as the human race we'll really
starve for that connection
and to feel those feelings and it's our
job
as artists to really dig down
deep and to go there to do the work
that others can't do because their lives
are so hectic
or so business oriented or whatever
there's a disconnect between heart and
head
and so it's it's really
us leading the way to let people know
that they can do it too
it's excellent it reminds me of um did
you listen to dolph lundgren's
ted talk no i didn't oh okay go so he
talked about
you know he has a successful career but
there was still a part of him that was
sort of i think he said frozen inside
and it was it's just
you wouldn't expect somebody that you
know was just strapping you know
big guy handsome to have you know to be
able to admit
some of these things that was really
touching and you know we talked about
similar things and so um it was just
interesting because
it was talking about you know being
successful but still feeling
old feelings inside not not a reversal
of something happening so it was just
fascinating i love that i love that
because i think that
we're a society of addiction because
the minute we feel discomfort we
do something go to our phone we have a
drink
go back to work right and so we
the key in life to changing our lives
changing our stories
is to be able to sit with that
discomfort to breathe into it and say
why do i feel uncomfortable at this
moment what is that
and and it might be the way we're
telling our story
it might be the way we're relating to
the world and does that fit us anymore
and this isn't an easy thing this is a
practice
right this is a form of meditation in a
sense
storytelling it isn't a form it is it is
meditation because the more you can be
present in your in your body and
feeling your feelings um and then
sharing those feelings will connect with
each other
and people are starved for that you know
that's why
i'm hired again and again and again is
because i really do care
and i really do want to hear people's
stories because
their stories help me with my stories
and we share you know this beautiful
like we feed each other and we build
upon
that positive energy even when we're
telling stories that are tough
we're just working through it and it's a
lot of work my
one of my speakers teases me charis she
says oh barbara
i'm going to change your middle name to
iterate because i iterate everything i'm
like
wait that doesn't feel right but it's
true because
there is spirit to words and
we've got to feel them so if we don't
feel the words
the audience won't either and that's
what they need so
that's our job i know you've worked a
lot with
the startup world and others in business
but for us with screenwriters and other
artists
they often have a fear of getting up and
presenting their own story they're fine
with their work or or maybe they feel
more comfortable with their work
how do you help someone with their story
knowing that there's going to be people
challenging them maybe outwardly so
poking holes in it or it's just a body
language a general feel of the room
that's not so embracing and they know
they still have to
keep their composure tell their story
stay on track
yes when i work with the entrepreneurs
you know a lot of times they're
challenged i'm not
exactly sure how it is in a pitch
meeting but
i can imagine with the entrepreneurs you
know this is their baby too
it's not so different than a writer
although as a fellow writer
those are your babies right and you're
like okay wait a minute you better be
nice to my kids in here
right so there's even it's even more so
um
but with the entrepreneurs as they get
up and they do the pitch and then they
open it up to q
a there's investors sitting in the
audience that are
you know very well educated
they've had successful exits they're the
ones investing
potentially writing a check if these
people are interesting enough so they
really want to do their due diligence
and they go in some of them not all of
them they can be
tough i love my investors but man
they're kind of crusty and rough around
the edges
and they go for the jugular and so
i work with my speakers on q a because
they need to be prepared to handle
that without getting defensive um
because it's easy to take it personally
but most of the time you'll notice when
a question
is asked by not when it's open to q a
and somebody stands up this is
having observed thousands of people ask
questions
somebody's standing up they're usually
not asking the question
to for you to really respond they're
asking the question
to show their knowledge and how smart
they are right you've seen that right
oh it happens in interviews as well yeah
oh well there you go
see yeah and so um
i work with them on all of that so
they're prepared
uh to to receive
the grilling that they're going to get
or those kind of weird questions that
they get that don't make any sense that
are really show off questions
um so let me show you how smart i am
questions right
so but but because they can be so kind
of
gruff and insensitive often
i just grill my own speakers and i'm
like okay here we go we're going to put
out the hardest questions
one two three and we really work
on them being straightforward
and as transparent as possible and when
they don't know
they don't know and they say you know
what i'm not sure
let's take that offline afterwards we'll
we'll have a conversation about it i'd
like to hear
get your input and so then all of a
sudden you defuse
and when you say to a person who's asked
a question who's maybe
slightly antagonistic i'm so glad you
brought up that point
i hadn't thought that through entirely
and i'd love to hear your thoughts on it
afterwards
so what happens is you defuse any
possible um
you know escalation of of
the person being antagonistic and you
then validate them you see
you say i see you i see you and what you
have to say is worthy
even though inside you might be gone oh
my god
right but you do validate them that's
the meaning beneath the words
right and then it's very difficult it's
very disarming when a person does that
when you think about that
in your own life when you're agitated
and somebody really sees you and says oh
i'm so sorry may we take this outside
and have a quick conversation
that was my oversight and then all of a
sudden it's like food
all the steam get outside you're like i
feel like a jerk
right so those kinds of things but it's
that ability to
go inside and say this is not about me i
don't need to let my ego step forward
and fight this fight i don't need to be
right
right i just need to say i'm here to
learn
and that's what startups are there to do
they don't know everything and the
investor knows that
and i would imagine that it's not so
different
in in the writing room right where you
go in and you pitch
to um to the group that you're pitching
to
how many do they usually pitch to two
three four six ten
you know i'm not yeah i'm not even sure
yeah i never pitched but or q a
sorry to interrupt but filmmaker q as
well i've definitely seen that where
you're right you're absolutely right
someone stands up and they're posing it
as a question
but they're really throwing out to the
filmmaker kind of like
they were challenging them in some way
even though you know they're just an
audience member
right let me show you how smart i am
again right and then
if you're taking that on the surface as
communication is
then you the receiver of the question is
missing the opportunity to go deeper
boy i'm so i very much appreciate that
you brought that up
i can see how you would see that you
know hadn't thought about it in that way
but i can see how you would say
and then what you do once you validate
the person because that's really
important
to validate them then you can drive the
train in the direction you want it to go
which is some ways the best thing to do
because
sometimes people are just um
grandstanding
to be seen right absolutely
and so it's so as a spokesperson when i
would appear on these television talk
shows
that's the thing that i learned is that
the host and hostess are just
there when when a guest is really worth
their weight in gold
the guest and you'll see this um the
ones that are really good on any of the
late night shows right they're
interviewed to death the guest that
comes on there the producer will call
and they will interview them for an hour
okay what is it you want to say
what stories do you want to tell and the
guest will say oh i'd like to tell the
story about my cat
no that doesn't sound good the producer
will say what else you got well i got
one about my girlfriend oh that's a good
one all right let's tell the story right
so the producer will weed through
the stories and it looks like they're
just having a conversation but it's all
scripted
everybody already knows the direction
it's going in right so
much like a late night talk show
when i would be a spokesperson i
realized the host and hostess just want
to kick back
they want me to drive the train and so
that's what i would do and they would
the minute they could tell that i was in
control they kind of breathed a
sigh of relief and then they would have
fun look at that skirt length i like
that boot what do you think sally
and they were having a lot more fun
because they felt like
i could drive the train and any
guest on any panel on any tv show
that is your job to come forward
and let the host and host just relax a
little
to tell the stories to engage
the audience and to really take your
time
and be in the moment what are some
common ways
people get their own stories wrong it's
a very interesting
question that i hadn't really thought of
the ways that people get their story
wrong
i would say when it comes to getting
your story wrong
[Music]
is you don't have a really clear
perception
of who you are and where you are
and so when that's out of step and out
of alignment and that usually occurs
when there's too much
ego or uh too much fragility
you know you're on a spectrum right so
you're either oh
i can't do that right or
you know there's a lot of false bravado
so when it gets too extreme in either
direction
is when the story gets wrong it gets
warped
and what we tell ourselves becomes our
beliefs
right and then those beliefs are the
things that keep us stuck
so it's really important to take a look
at how much ego do i have in this
you can feel it in your body was it
sanford meisner
that said the body is the instrument i
believe it was the acting coach
and excuse me youtube world if i got
that wrong
but i believe he was the one
that said that and which is brilliant
because i say that to my speakers you
know and i quote him and hopefully
that's the right one
but you can really feel in your skin
when you're when you're in alignment and
when you're in alignment
you are telling your truth
and that truth is short sweet and to the
point it doesn't take a lot of words to
say
and it has the tone
and the beauty and the magic of a church
bell i
i don't live very far from the the san
juan
mission and every hour
they ding the bell right
and the sound it's an old beautiful
church bell
and the sound is pure and gorgeous
and that's what truth feels like you can
feel that in your body there's no
resistance
it's when we feel resistance in our body
that we're not being true to our story
or who we are i should say you know
that's a story we're telling
but it doesn't mean that we're being
true to who we are or
what we could be and sometimes things
will feel false
when we start to try to tell stories in
a new way because
we've been we've worn out those steps
right you've created a groove in the
steps if you've ever been to an
like uh let's say to
the the white house you can see the
steps and when you go inside and take
the tour
there's marble steps and they're all
worn right there's grooves
there that's what we do when we tell the
same story over and over we create these
grooves
and they feel comfortable and you know
that they're going to be worn that way
but then when we start to realize that
story doesn't fit us anymore
and we take new steps over into the
place that's level all of a sudden that
doesn't
well i'm not used to that maybe i'm
lying
but but eventually it will become true
and you'll know that that's where you
want to be and it will
push you and it will become your new
normal and it will resonate with you
that way but most of the time i find
when people are out of alignment
with their story and they're not being
really true to who they are and what
they
want to be uh then
they'll feel it in their bodies have you
ever had to
[Music]
have a meeting about that in terms of
you
you know meet the person you find out
kind of their
line of events and what their agenda is
or you know what their
what their startup is but then there's
just something off about the story and
you have to let them know
it's a disconnect and i'm really sorry
and then of course there'd be resistance
of course if anybody was told that about
their own lives but
and then trying to sort of work with
them on allowing what you see as their
real story to come forward
yes that's very observant so
both in the pitch world when i work with
entrepreneurs and in the speech writing
world
there are for the for the
for the entrepreneurs often it's that
they're so early stage they can't see
all of the
all the things they need to see yet
right because it's an evolution
right you progress along the way and
your story gets tighter and tighter and
tighter and you fill those holes
uh you pitch where you are and then the
next pitch will never be the same as the
first one or
it will be there'll be elements that are
the same but hopefully you will have
grown the company
and so it will have evolved along with
you
so it's important as an entrepreneur to
continually iterate
but what happens is because i know the
stories the story forms so well those
rules that i
so resisted have really come in handy
that i can hear when there's
in there's something incongruent right
so when there's this um
there's a hole and i'm saying to and
i've had as a result
of me grilling the entrepreneur so
deeply
they are like okay what is this lady
gonna let up on me
but then they will have actually once
they realized that that
the question i'm asking is just an
audience question um
that it's not making sense your startup
that you keep saying you're going to go
to this target market
but i don't see it with the product that
you have so when
things don't fit together just from an
average person looking at it right
because i'm not an expert in their field
that's actually my strength because i'm
not an expert in someone's field
but i can so that makes me be able to
hear even more so
when something doesn't fit together and
so
um what happens is they have to
go and back to the drawing table and
look at why it's not working and i've
had
quite a few companies pivot as a result
meaning that they've had to
go and revamp their product and the
market that they were going toward
so it would be more in alignment and
it's helped them
so that's been a big epiphany because
they were sure that that was the
direction that they were supposed to be
going in
so it's often that's just blind spots
that they can't see
right so that becomes very clear to me
as the audience
when it comes to my speakers and their
own personal stories
that boils down a lot to
[Music]
the their relationship to those stories
are they willing to let go of a story
that the way that they've
been telling it um when amy came to me
she had been telling she'd only been
speaking to high schools
for an hour so she had tons of time
eight minutes was a big departure
so we had to get really serious as i
joke with my speakers it's time to pull
out the chainsaw
rumor fire it up and carve right
but that allows things to rise to the
top so when
when i sit down with the speaker let's
say you come to me and say barbara i've
got a 10-minute talk and i say okay
great
why don't you give me what you think you
want to talk about in 300 words
and so you'll write me 1300 words and
from that
i'll upload it to google docs and then
i'll dissect it
and ask i'll i'll write all of these
questions and i'll highlight them and
you and i'll sit down
for an hour and a half and we'll go
through one by one
and because of that reason of talking on
the surface
like i was mentioning when we
communicate that's how most people write
when they're not writers and even
writers do right
and so i keep going deeper because i'm
emotionally demanding as i tell my
speakers i want to know
how you feel how you felt in that moment
where you were you know let me feel that
too
don't be stingy and so a lot of times
people
won't tell me a full story and i'll say
to them
i feel like you're hiding something and
they'll be like
what how did you know
and i'll because it will what's not
there
will tell me what's missing
omission omission it's lying by omission
and so it's not that people are
inherently lying but
i can feel something's not right
i feel very very deeply when people have
secrets
it's it comes it bounce i don't know
what the secret is
but it comes flying off the page at me
right
or in conversation because i have to go
deep with my speakers and i'll feel when
they're not
opening up because when you're an open
book it's fluid
right you know we were just talking
about this the other day
david and i in terms of certain people
in interviews are willing to go
to certain lengths and other people only
want to present
all the things that are positive they
don't ever want to go into
struggles that they had and why
certain people sort of fall into that
camp and why others are just like
like you said open books and they're
willing to say you know i was sleeping
on a couch
and there was no money in the bank and
my life was over
and i think there's there's something
where certain people don't want to tell
certain parts of their story because
there's a lot of shame
behind it and so but sometimes those are
the things that make you connect to them
they make you connect to a story whether
it's a script and then there's a
character that's not
telling something so do you often see
with maybe people that are
you know advanced degrees or whatever
they don't want to go into failure
but sometimes that component of failure
is really what's gonna
just make you connect in the audience in
that eight minutes
yeah i say to my speakers there is no
story without struggle
period if you don't have a struggle
we can just close the books now and say
goodbye because
we all had struggle and i like to go
into those more micro moments so you
know how i said
that i take story and i really make it
narrow for my speakers
and i consolidate it so it's not a lot a
bunch of stories
it's not too big it's not too high it is
very very concise so we can go into
the the story and how it made them feel
which is again giving
the audience permission to to say oh
that happened to me too right and then
you're having this connection because
they say that
when you feel what you're saying you
actually
your brain waves send out something
that's what science says right now
that the audience's brain waves are in
sync with yours but it's a feeling
that's then kind of
mind control obi-wan kenobi
but it's it's deeper than that and it's
it's a satisfying
feeling but so there's that
there's also when i work with executives
sometimes
because there's a there's a narrative
that we americans have which is the
individual
and the individual reigns supreme that's
a lot of why people
don't want to talk about their struggles
they just want to talk about
all of their triumphs and how great they
are
and how much they've achieved you know
[Music]
it's a it's a reason why there are ghost
writers and speech writers are not so
different than ghost writers right
most speechwriters do not identify
themselves um but i do
um i sell my speakers i'm going to let
people know that's
that you're working with a speechwriter
because that's what i do
but most feature writers won't more and
more ghost writers are starting to put
their names on book covers now
but they didn't in the past and
people feel threatened by that so that
again if that's an ego
issue and if you feel like you can't
tell people that you're working with a
speech writer who helped elevate your
story it's your story in the end
right but what we speech writers are
here to do
and good storytellers are here to do as
i tell my
speakers i'm here to make you look good
right
i'm here too and i think also there's an
element of fear for people that don't
want to talk about struggle
what if i tell it wrong what if i over
share
what if i and and so my speakers will
tell me a lot of personal details
that will never go from the page to the
stage it won't even make the page
right um but it helps me understand
their journey and empathize
even more deeply with them and connect
with them
and that then i filter through it so the
audience
feels the tension feels the pain
but they didn't overshare in a way that
was like oh that was uncomfortable
awkward right right and i think people
worry about that
and they you know we put a lot of
emphasis on brand
uh these days with all these social
media with all the social media
platforms
and i i think that it's important to
kind of walk that fine line
to be able to share hey i'm having a bad
day and here's what happened
you know and that's how we connect
without the struggle who cares
so is that something that you've had to
work with certain people on in terms of
letting go and allowing certain things
that maybe
they don't think are as favorable and
don't want them out there
but in in the bigger scheme of their
story the bigger you know
like picture of it that you feel is
necessary to get
audience empathy as well my speakers
have been pretty good on a spectrum
they've been
pretty good at embracing the struggle
aspects at first
especially the ones that tend to be
engineers uh
not all of them i love my engineer peeps
depending on you know who they are
one i worked with once that was a doctor
and an engineer
yes and so he was having a little bit of
problem embracing the struggle
but then once he he could step back and
look at it and he was like oh wait a
minute oh i see
oh i read this to my wife and she was
like that's really good i
really never knew what you did before
right
and then all of a sudden now there's an
emotional component because when we can
tell a story especially in a
highly expert category expert category
whether it's medicine mathematics it
doesn't matter what it is if we can put
that story into real world context we
don't need to know the fine point
details you can go
and give that powerpoint presentation to
your fellow
mathematicians right but but how do you
let that how do you translate that for
mere mortals like myself
to understand how what you do has real
world
implications and that you struggled to
get to that you just didn't sit down one
day and
say oh i'm going to be a field medalist
and become this fabulous
mathematician and this is how i'm going
to do it no
you sucked a lot along the way and it
was painful
and your peers spanked you along the way
and you know really beat up on you and
still you
persevered because you knew that you had
something and you had to keep going
you know it's not easy so
that struggled to varying degrees
some people totally get it and embrace
it and they're like oh
yes and others are like
lukewarm but they still go along with it
because
usually somebody higher up has hired me
if i'm working with people that are
academics
um and i will defer i'll say well you
know your boss the dean
will have said uh you need to do it this
one they're like all right
or or you know whoever the the champ
vice chancellor of the school those
kinds of things i work a lot with the
universities so
you did a podcast with two screenwriters
any takeaways from that
it was interesting so the the one woman
was very nervous
one of the screenwriters was very
nervous about
pitching she always felt self-conscious
and you know what should i do what are
the tips that i need so i gave a lot of
tips on
on how to really interact with your
audience
it doesn't really matter who your
audience is but especially in
in any kind of emotional artistic
endeavor
it's about telling that story from a
place of heart like how does it matter
to you
and to go in and
to to say so this is one of the things i
tell my speakers and i i believe i said
it on the podcast but if i didn't this
is a bonus
uh the story is never about you it's
about your north star so you need to
identify that early on you know when i
sit down with the speaker
that's what we do early on you know
where do you want to leave the audience
what's the one
idea that you want them to think about
or act upon when they leave the theater
what is it what do you want them to
share or do
and when
they start to get nervous the speaker as
they often do
that's a sign that their ego is taking
over and so
the way i re direct it is to say hey
this isn't about you this is about the
message that you have that one thing
that we identified at the end that you
want them to walk away with
and think about or act upon or share and
so
when you start to feel nervous you say
you know what i have something that's
bigger than me
it's greater than me i'm on a mission
and i'm there
to follow that north star and
so for amy we identified that love
was her mission for her ted talk and
that she needed to share that people
needed to know that you can be loved and
that you should love
it's never said in the talk but that was
what i'd say when you
what is your message she'd be love and
she was amazing
that way she embraced everything and
and so when you go to pitch that takes
the pressure off of you
because it's the story what is your
storyline why did you write these
characters
why did you do any of this right
is it social justice you know what is it
that you want to know and is it
is it women's issues lgbtq
what is it that you want us to know
about these characters
and that's what i love about life right
now too is that
the voices that have not had the stage
are now starting to have the stage but
their messages
are universal they're emotional and
they're what we've all
been through and when you hit those
emotional touch points
you can really spark your audience's
imagination
feeling it and then and then thinking
about all the possibilities
so that's what i would want for
people who are going in to pitch
anything but especially tv or film
to go in and to always know their north
star what is the one thing you want that
audience to know about what you're
working on
what you care about this baby and if you
don't have anything
that is you feel like it's not totally
hitting the mark tell a personal story
right and and when you tell that
personal story
it says so much more than facts and
figures could ever say
because it it tells you the layers of
you
and it lets people walk away
oh wow i never looked at it that way and
that applies to my life too so you
create this connection
but again that's i believe that's one of
the things that i
talked about in this podcast to get over
the fear
some people's fears are so deep and
they'll ask me should i take medication
you know should i take an antidepressant
seriously and i'm i'm miss natural like
you know i don't
i really like should i take this cold
medicine i don't know
i'm that much of a freak right i'm a
supplement girl
so i say take magnesium
be careful with meditation before you
speak because meditation can really
bring you into this beautiful zen place
but you need a little bit of that energy
a little bit of that angst
on the stage to keep you sort of
percolating up there
and to share that feeling you need to
take that energy and if the meditation
can make you flat
um and so you have to strike that
balance and i had a speaker who
meditated once and i was like
oh no stop
and i'm all for meditation but do it
early in the morning don't do it like
you know 15 minutes before you go on
stage
and uh so
[Music]
what about too much coffee though
because sometimes coffee can be good
i know this seems like so trivial but no
no it actually can
really shift in how you interact with
people
and how you're perceived and it could be
that you've just had a great cup of like
espresso
and people like wow you're intense but
you're just like wow i've just had this
thing and you think
yeah everything's crystal clear and
wonderful but do you ever
talk about caffeine moderation i do i do
so
we're kind of like camels i tell all my
speakers the day before i want you to
drink
eight glasses of water okay all
throughout the day
at least eight full-size glasses wow
and then that way you'll be properly
hydrated for the next day the day that
you speak because we rarely drink the
amount of water we're supposed to drink
the day of right because we're visiting
we're busy we're traveling we're
whatever it is or backstage
so hydrate hydrate hydrate
if you drink caffeine just drink the
same amount that you always drink
and i say that speaking is a sport so i
want you to stretch out like an athlete
and i want you to eat light so avoid the
carbs
i want you to be slightly hungry when
you deliver because that also helps with
the clarity of the mind
the carbs can kind of bring you down a
little bit hey i feel good how about
another croissant over here on the table
you can have that afterwards as a reward
but before
you know really think light think a
little piece of protein
um a little bit of veggies just
something really crisp and clean
and then um you'll be you'll deliver
your synapses will fire a lot better and
don't over caffeinate if you drink one
cup of coffee in the morning or one cup
cup of tea stick to that no more no less
because other
otherwise to your point we get excited
and we're like oh there's no water
around i'll just drink some more tea
or some more coffee and then that will
tighten the vocal cords
and dry them out and you don't want that
you want to keep those vocal cords nice
and warm and
and happy and water is the thing that
will do that
also herbal tea can dry up dry out your
throat so be careful of the herbal tea
but so it's not a trivial question
i'm kind of a maniac about it and then
the stretching is important too
because we get tight in the neck and we
get tired in the lower back especially
because we're probably rehearsing
the days before and even maybe that
morning so stretch it out
and remember to breathe as i say to my
speakers if you don't
breathe you can't smile
and if you don't smile how will the
audience know you're having fun
so always remember to breathe when
you're
when you're um working on all of these
just the rehearsing and then the actual
day
and the pausing will help you do that
and i work with my
so i take my speakers we we write the
story
when when they're going to the stage we
write the story
we transfer that story we begin to build
slides so
it's actually more like a video they
click on emotional
words so they don't click at an end of a
sentence or idea they click on emotional
words
so the image and the words as the story
crescendos
the image and the words marry to each
other so they really stick with the
audience
so it's very deliberate i have to work
with my speakers
with this technique all the way through
so they can deliver and the pauses are
as important
as the vocal variation as the way they
move and
manage the stage what are some of those
emotional words
well it really depends on on there isn't
a
particular word it usually is the
feeling and so if there's a
uh i'm trying to think
in some of my talks well in charis's
talk
rap on trial she talks about being an
expert witness
and at this particular part of the story
she's sitting
as the expert witness and she is
the there's a lawyer there in front of
her who's grilling her
and she has said you know the wit the
the the evidence will
prove the the person who's on trial this
rap music artist
he's going to get off because the
evidence is so clear
that you know he didn't do this that
he's not guilty
and
when she's presented all of her evidence
and this is the first time she's ever
been an expert witness
she's and she's unbelievable this woman
the way she she delivers
ideas crisp and clear and concise and
so in the story she's just told the jury
why that he should be you know let go
and the lawyer walks up to her
and says um
i can't remember exactly what he says
but he slams down a pistol
on the the the stand in front of her
and says oh really is this what you'd
consider
you know and i he and then the audience
sees the gun the jury sees the gun they
see that moment and so when we click for
that
when she says and he slam we click for a
picture of a pistol
up close and personal and boom
you know and so she really drives home
that point
um and she says emotions trump
logic every time and we see that gun
up there and we feel it so it really the
story tells me where the images go ah
okay so there's not particular words no
it's really
yeah thank you for asking to clarify
that but it's really
the the story is the foundation that
tells me oh my gosh this needs an image
and not as much text does that take away
text takes away because the audience
doesn't know whether to read or listen
to you
so you have to be very deliberate in
your talk in the way you use text
so again in charis's talk there's a part
where she talks about
about guns and about
rappers so if this was a white rapper
who was on trial it would be very
different
and so we actually put white rapper plus
um gun equals he's gone astray
right so i needed to do that i came up
with this idea i was like how do we
visually show this
it wasn't the best way but it's all we
had right
and then we showed black rapper plus gun
equals a thug destined for prison
and so to see those words on there and
you can actually hear the audience gasp
because the difference is startling and
um you know it can be a very powerful
thing but we animated those words so
they couldn't read ahead
right we spoon feed the audience the
text as we
need otherwise they'll read ahead and
that will take them out of the story
so that's how i that's why and how
i don't use text very often and i if i
use it i use it very very strategically
and sparingly
you know when you're about to go into
pitch or you have to give a speech
you're going to do an audition whatever
it is there's the nerves
and i think there's some people that
want to just be alone with the material
and not speak to anybody because they're
so like i've got to get this right i've
got to get this right
and then there's others that they're
just chatting away and maybe that's part
of their process
it makes them less nervous what do you
think
wow as a kind of an ambivert i don't
know
i don't trust those people who are
talking away beforehand
i am just like a worrier right so i
worry about my own speeches ugh
i so i i gave a ted talk and that was
and i did the ted talk because i was
putting my speakers through all these
paces
but i'd never tried them myself so i
tried the paces and i
suffered oh did i suffer from just not
ever
doing i was like oh i called each one of
my speakers i said will you forgive
me for everything i've ever done to you
they're laughing oh
you're funny but because the process is
difficult right
it's it's a lot but in the end it's the
thing that keeps you
moving forward but i i can't imagine and
and meeting your mark and crossing over
the finish line
i can't imagine having chatted any with
anyone
beforehand right um i mean that's one of
the things
in terms of speakers to me some of the
most interesting speakers are either
introverts
or ambiverts because there's an inner
world
right that's what speaking is it's
toggling between this inner world and
outer world that's what writing
is and so i find that the
the introverts the the ambiverts tend to
be
more um inter-world
reflective and that's also very needed
for
an audience that doesn't always have a
lot of time to take their own time to
reflect
and i think that that needs a little bit
of time alone
or with a coach just sort of working on
things beforehand
or even the day like the hour of
because sometimes i've been of a
different school of thought if i have to
do something that i'm very nervous about
it actually can help me sometimes to to
converse with others in the waiting room
but then other times it spreads my
energy too thin
and then i'm not focused so i really
have to kind of pick and choose when i
do that
because i'm probably more of the
introvert class but just
you know i just wondered if there was
because you know there's always the
school of thought well that actor
or that musician whatever they they hang
out in the back they don't come to set
they're not you know but maybe that's
part of their process because there's a
you know real backlash they don't want
to be part of the group maybe that's how
they kind of preserve
their their who they are their character
their energy
and i just wondered if you had thoughts
on i i feel those people
yeah me too because i don't have an
infinite amount of energy
and you know extroverts will take the
energy from the room and use it
right so it's their fuel my husband's an
extrovert
and and he's fueled by people and i'm
fueled by people in a certain way to a
certain point
if that makes sense for all those
introverts out there it does
and extroverts right um
and that doesn't mean that i don't love
people and don't enjoy being with them i
i thoroughly do but i have a cut-off
point
absolutely an expiration point where i'm
like okay i gotta go recharge my
batteries with the
cats over there where it's quiet or
hiking
or hiking right exactly i love the
outdoors and that's a really great
restorative thing to do
the beach just go walk on the beach i
mean
so i need that i need that quiet time
and that reflective time
to really process it all because i'm i'm
also having very deep conversations like
probably therapy deep
right um but
uh but so it doesn't mean that there's
one right way or
one wrong way um it's really just
you have to touch base with you and say
how am i feeling right now did i overdo
it
is that was that too much and it depends
on the type of speech you're giving so
if you're giving a speech where you have
to memorize everything and all of my
speakers have to
the when they're the shorter speeches
they have to memorize everything
when they're the longer speeches so some
of my speakers speak for an hour
i have them craft the open and craft the
clothes because as i say to them
speeches are like flying you know
takeoff and landings are the most
dangerous so you got to pay attention
so i really get them to craft that open
and that clothes which are very short
but then they got to know the middle and
some of my speakers actually will
memorize not verbatim but darn near
an entire hour so i have some
incredible speakers that are just able
to do that
very gifted so um
it really depends if you're giving a
powerpoint presentation that's a whole
different thing
that's again you might have a messaging
craft for the beginning
and a message that you want to leave a
heartfelt message you want to leave at
the end
and then in the middle you just sort of
follow
the the trail of of your slides
that'll prompt you when you see them
that's what i do with my speakers too
when they have slides i say
let the image the slide be your guide it
will remem
remind you what you're supposed to be
saying here and it does it's amazing
that way
think about someone like steve jobs i
mean this is off topic and
if we don't want to yeah but steve jobs
was just such a great
i mean you just kind of hung on his
every word when he gave a speech i know
larry ellison is
similar from some of the speeches i've
watched and i'm not even
in that world but i just find that he
the way he delivers
a story the way he his timing
different different people really do
have like this
captivating almost like rock star
quality that you want to hang on their
every word even if you're not interested
in the subject matter
and i'm not even sure if if is that
something someone's born with
or do they learn it over time
i'm of the firm believer
under the firm belief of the fact that
i think that we all inherently have it
it's just that some of us
dig for it some of it comes more easily
than others
some of us have had traumas that keep it
buried
i've had speakers that i just couldn't
get to be natural
and i worked and worked and worked with
them to really just be more present
when i had conversations with they were
lovely and wonderful
but the minute they got on stage it was
like child star
and then you know so there became a lack
of trust in themselves that they weren't
enough i
i think that's probably the most best
message i can
have and i believe that when you look
like you're conversational like a steve
jobs or larry ellison
or any of the speakers that are just you
want to
say well look can we meet for a tea and
talk right
i'm not even going to pitch you right
exactly i just want to hear more about
what other store what other stories you
got for me because they're really good
and i'm engaged
let's go right right um
they've worked at that and they
really really really enjoy it i mean
that's the gift of storytelling for me
this sense of wonder
i really love to hear people's stories
and
i wonder what it was it's like to be
them
right i can never be them but i wonder
what it's like
to be them and how much i see when they
share these stories how much we have in
common
so for me i believe we're all gifted now
how many of us use the gift and do the
hard work that it takes to look like a
steve jobs one day
he might have started that practice when
he was young right
he other people
may have had to cover it up with the
life circumstances
right but it was important to him
i didn't know him but i can tell you
that if you sat down with him he would
tell you that it was important and he
saw the
he felt more than he saw he felt the
power of story
and what it could do for not only
himself
but the people around him how it can
motivate
and inspire them and tear them down
right so it really
he was strategic and
when you tell stories for good you can
move
mountains you truly truly can and again
the audience is hungry for it they need
it the audience meaning me you
and everyone we feel isolated and more
alone than ever before it doesn't matter
that we have devices and ways to connect
we're lonely because we're not feeling
what we need to be feeling seeing a
picture
reading a post that's nice and all but
to sit down with you here today
and really connect and to hear all your
beautiful thoughtful questions
and all the love that you put into film
courage
oh thank you you're welcome i mean that
from the bottom of my
heart you've been my inspiration and
watching this channel has been like oh
my god i can't wait to watch another one
i drove all the way to northern
california and listened to
the ken oh yeah oh my god
amazing thank you you're welcome but
they're so thoughtful these questions
and so
insightful and you've done a lot of
personal work to get there
thank you you have and that allows me
to be able to i say oh kindred spirit
and we're able to talk to each other
because i know that you know and that
you understand it doesn't mean that
when we're talking to other people who
don't understand
that we can't still have a conversation
with them they need us even more
right because they then know
we aren't alone right we're filling
ourselves up from the inside and when we
can do that
we can then teach others how to do that
as well to see
the best in themselves and that's what
film courage does for me
seeing that knowing i'm not alone when
i'm scared out of my mind to go to the
next step of writing
right and experimenting for all the
reasons you could say oh i'm this or i'm
that or oh how could i be
no you're not alone just watch a video
and you'll hear somebody else with that
through that too oh okay
great so you know
thank you thank you yeah that's why you
know it was
david's idea for the blog the film
courage and then we started doing the
podcast and
he puts equal amount of time into the
questions as well but that was why we
wanted to do it is we felt
a connection as well hearing other
people's stories and you're right it's
you know you can have twitter streams
and all these great videos and it's not
the same as
seeing someone face to face and just
hearing a story
yeah without judging right just sitting
down and hearing a real story
because we're hearing so many
manufactured stories and i'm hearing
you know the word narrative being tossed
around and hijacked in ways that i don't
really
appreciate especially in the corporate
world
because they're saying that they're
telling stories but stories
really they're about revealing something
that you're a little bit afraid to
reveal
to say you know what this took me a long
time to get here
and i'm embarrassed to tell you that i
still make these mistakes
you know but i do and just by telling
that
telling the story of of your life of
a place you tripped up um and it's
genuine you're not telling it because
you are looking for a strategy to get
somebody to do something like a chess
piece
you're doing it because you really want
to let people know you're not alone
life is an existential journey and
none of us are going to come out of it
unscathed right so to know
that you fell and skinned your knee too
you did i did too
oh my gosh i didn't see that step right
um that's what story does and that's my
purpose in the world
through story that's my north star is to
let the the people
around know they're not alone and that
please sit down and have heartfelt
conversations
with the people that you care about
maybe strangers you don't even know
you know we're each other's angels but
we've got to take the time
to and the risk of vulnerability
to start to to share and say wow i'm so
glad that you crossed my path
today without getting political
then there's also disinformation which
is its own brand of storytelling
so it's it's very easy to tell
especially in this digital age
we can craft whatever story we want
and it's empowering but it can also be
you know very damaging at the same time
yes so
i think now more than ever it's
important for rhetoric to come back
being taught in the schools to
understand
that again what's happening in the
political sphere or wherever that type
of rhetoric is a tool it's what they do
it's
what they hone so when you listen to
their messages
you're hearing oh well that's the logic
side it's like two lawyers
in a trial right oh that's a logic
stance well if you don't have a stance
then
you know try something different
it once you understand that and you can
step
back from the emotions of it and you can
feel the feelings right that's sitting
with the discomfort that i was talking
about earlier
you can see it from afar you're the
witness of it
but you are not swept up in
the the misinformation or the
disinformation right
that you're not believing everything
that's coming out
on either side because they're spun
in the ways they need to spin them so
they can win
with their constituents
so
i mean perfect place to go is social
media go to facebook and see people who
go on about
political things and you could
just say the person on the right or the
person on the left they've kind of
melded into one
the energy of what they're saying isn't
so different right
it's true because they're emotionally
whipped up but that isn't communication
that's just screaming at a wall and then
what do we get right so there's always
been bad journalism there's always been
um rhetoric but if you don't understand
how those mechanisms work you will fall
prey to them
and believe they are true if that makes
sense
it does i think there was a comment i
read what is it um
journalism is getting out of story
somebody doesn't want out
everything else is advertising i'm not
sure
what that is but that's a good one and
that was hold on it's going to come to
me
um she ran the washington post
oh catherine graham thank you okay that
was kathryn graham
okay was that maybe that was one of the
quotes okay
that's it see i've been found out yeah
i've have you been stalking i have i
have in preparation for this interview
yeah very good so okay so that was for
you because i thought it was i was also
doing research on the movie richard
jewell
and there was some backlash against that
as well so sorry i wasn't sure if it was
on
underneath that trailer there's so much
i know okay so so that was one of your
instagrams so that was one of my
instagrams there we go
it's very good excellent good good yes
and that's true
that is true that that sums up the news
when i worked in tv news
our slogan was if it bleeds it leads
right so when you start to understand
that
news is there to be sensational because
sensational things sell
and we would laugh when i worked in news
because we i would go into the edit
suite
and there would be these black holes
where the commercials would go and we
would look
one day i was sitting there with a
friend and he said look see that black
hole right there
and i go yeah and he said that's the
most
precious expensive thing in all of this
piece because the black holes was were
they advertising and the advertising
is what paid the bills kept the likes on
and gave her salaries
at the time and when you start looking
at things in that way then can truth
ever really totally come out
right yeah and journalists that is not
a dig against journalists
journalists have a really uh and there's
a lot of great journalists
i'm a firm believer believer in
journalism absolutely but you have to be
specific you have to really work hard to
find the journalists that you
that resonate with you and that you
understand that they have an opinion too
that's right and so if you're going to
read the new york times you have to say
well
i know that that journalist is most
likely going to be on the left unless
they
say otherwise if i read the wall street
journal i'm going to say well
economics are going to drive their
that's the lens they look through
right and then when i do that i start to
understand that that's
who pays their bills that's the black
hole in their
editorial piece right you know that's if
you open the wall street journal or
the washington post you'll see where the
advertisements are
and that's what pays and keeps the
lights on
and so it doesn't mean that they're
totally influenced by it we but as
journalists we can only do
the best we can do with what we have we
do our best to try to be as neutral as
we can
but we're human there are
two areas that i specialize in the first
is i work with
entrepreneurs on crafting their pitch
to investors so they can raise
early stage funds seed rounds a
b or early stage where they're raising
anywhere from
half a million and up right half a
million to maybe a million two
that's the early stage and so they have
to go out and pitch
to often angel investors or sometimes
venture funds right
and really have a tight story
that hooks them from the beginning and
then
they usually open it up to q a where the
investor will grill them so that's one
area of expertise that i have
and then the other that i concentrate on
is working with
entrepreneurial speakers not
entrepreneurs per se but they tend to be
more motivational speakers
or speakers with a deeper broader
heartfelt message that they need to get
out they'll often speak to corporations
and i've worked with people also in
executives but they they have to be
daring executives they can't be
executives that are willing to toe the
party line
they have to be the ones that are really
ready to open up and be
more transparent most executives are you
know sort of
somewhat stoic and hiding behind the ceo
title
so but those are the two areas of of
expertise speeches and and pitches
and how did you come to this you
attended a ted talk right so
you know a series of accidents
so the um bottom fell out of the market
when i was producing large-scale live
events
and so of course the first thing budget
to be slashed were the events themselves
and then i went to
uh to a um
techostangel pitch event and i met a
tech coast angel
who introduced me to another tech ghost
angel
who was um producing a ted event
and i went to him and said i can do i
can be a speechwriter i've never written
a speech in my life by the way
um except for these 90-second pitches
right but i felt like i could do it
and and apparently i convinced him and
he's like okay great i'll give you eight
speakers
and then that's how i got into that and
i was like okay eight speakers and how
many weeks do i have
well it's in three weeks okay that'll be
good
and so it was like round the clock but i
learned
so much and volunteering i highly
recommend
it just jump in and that's what i did i
volunteered because
you know there wasn't a job to be had so
i was like well
jump in and embrace this fully and that
gave me permission to make mistakes and
to just experiment
i was like well i got nothing to lose
nobody's paying me at the end
right and that's what i did with the
with the
fast pitches for the tech host angels
and then also again
for the tedx events and i've probably
written
over 100 tedx speeches so i
really learned a lot from those two and
it was
about three years in that i started
actually you know confessing well people
would say what do you do for a living
and i'm saying like oh i'm a
speechwriter
and i couldn't believe that it was
coming out of my mouth until i saw their
faces and they were like oh really
like politics they'd say like oh no no
no no
and that was interesting because often
people will say to you what do you do
for a living
and i realized that i was getting these
really you know horrific horrified looks
so i thought okay how can i change this
up right and so
then and and have fun because i wasn't
having fun when i saw their reaction
so then people came to me so what do you
do for a living and i'd say well
ever give a speech and i get one of two
answers
probably 95 of the time just like a look
of
horror and sheer terror on their oh i
hate speaking
like they want to run away or i get that
one you know few
crazy people are like i love speaking
it's fabulous you know those are crazy
extroverts
but then i found when i asked a question
then i it was a new way to get into
because i had engaged i had emotions
around it
everybody has it was a jerry seinfeld
that said
i'd rather be in the coffin than give
the eulogy
right and it's so true and then
but but once they had that feeling
around it then they were really way more
inquisitive
and it was really fun so that's one one
recommendation i have for anybody who's
a writer
just have fun with what you do and don't
apologize a lot of times we
apologize for what we're doing like for
three years i was like
oh yeah well i do this thing called ted
have you ever heard of it in the
beginning people are like
ted what's that you know i'd say well
it's technology education design they'd
be like
right and now everybody wants to talk
yeah yes
totally changed exactly so uh
yeah that's how i got in into all of it
had you been to toastmasters prior to
that i
had been i had been doing toastmasters
and toastmasters is wonderful i
i highly recommend that people go to
toastmasters especially because there's
varying degrees of there are some really
accomplished people in
in toastmasters and it will take you
through to many levels
it won't take you to the stage in the
way that i work with my speakers
but it is a wonderful workout once a a
week and if you can join a club
where you can um work with
uh go to do the workout once a week a
club that
meets every week not a club that meets
only twice a month
they lose their momentum but the clubs
that meet once a week
you will really start to work that
muscle and feel
like wow hey i feel like i
nailed that question and and you'll take
it out into the real world and you'll
find that you you really you be a jo
build your speaking confidence i've seen
people who were barely able to speak or
completely nervous or almost to tears
and six months later you wouldn't even
recognize them amazing transformations
so especially for business i highly
recommend toastmasters
but if you want to go beyond that to
really to the big money
to you know where my speakers are making
anywhere from 15
000 and up for speech
then you really you know you really want
to work with somebody who takes you to
the next level
you talked about people obsessing over
their problems and then those
problems become bigger i was wondering
if you see people obsessing over
their careers and their lack of
opportunity or whatever and then that
becomes
a self-fulfilling prophecy so they're
obsessing over the fact that
they're not getting this they're not
getting that they're not being able to
pitch to someone whatever
and that actually that obsession
actually stops them from getting other
opportunities yeah that's a big one
because what's happening is
when we're focused on what we're not
getting we can't see all the things we
are right
and so we're missing out we're very
focused if we could just do that and
focus on something that
is working for us and we can shift that
you know and it can be just sometimes
just an inch over it's not very far
but we can get into that comfort zone
that groove
where it's familiar and we kind of like
at some point we have to admit the fact
and i can tell you from my own life
that i have liked sometimes
complaining until i didn't like
one day you sit up and you go why why
i'm complaining all this time
well that's crazy and it all of a sudden
you outgrow that complaining and because
i never asked myself what's my
motivation for complaining right
and so you get fixated on what's not
happening
and then you're not really living your
life you're and and then what happens is
it's like have you ever bought a new car
and all of a sudden you see oh my gosh
there's my car over there and there's my
you never really noticed how many of
your car
there was on the road right uh-huh and
you beep at them yeah yeah yeah wait
hey how's it going right i know you yeah
yeah yeah
so it's not so different than that
so what happens is you see
all of that negativity that you've been
fixating on and you look up and you're
like well i see that over there
hey negativity over there that matches
that and you start to look for all the
things that are familiar and they become
negative they're negative things right
because that's all you can see at this
point it's what you've been nurturing
but if you shift that over and you start
to and it's not comfortable this
you know it makes i don't want to
trivialize this in any way because it's
a lot of work
you know as i used to say when i began
this this awareness of my language and i
was like trying to to steer a luxury
liner with a popsicle stick like oh my
god
right because i was falling back into
bad habits that i had had
um instead of you know but
but but just the acknowledging that i
had those bad habits and that i was
falling back into them
was actually my release but it was a
daily hourly
process of saying this can be better
and i can start to see the beauty in the
world and i can start to believe that
there's good in the world and i will see
it doesn't make me pollyanna
right a lot of us are complainers or
we're
sarcastic or negative because we're
really soft-centered
and we're putting other things and
people down
and in competitive business up what are
they now look at that
kind of you know because there's plenty
of room for everyone
frankly but when we do that we're just
trying to to save ourselves and
you know not get hurt but the reality is
our strength comes from
saying there's plenty of room for
everyone and i think you're wonderful
too and you've taught me a lot
right and i can learn more from you
because i have and i still struggle with
it
i have the american mentality which is
i am an individual and individuals get
things done
you know but it's ridiculous because i
mean einstein was a genius but do you
think he became a genius on his own
no he had a mother and father he was
nurtured he had people that
you know said along the way hey you've
got potential
you know and none of us do it alone
it's ridiculous to think that we do it
alone
we all need help
and we all we're all better from the
people around us and we need to give
them credit and the more we do that and
we take the light off of us because when
we're trying to say
you know i'm so good we're really
calling for attention
when did you realize you wanted to hone
your story probably
yeah when it needed an overhaul you mean
yeah seriously you know i think there
are points in our lives where we get the
call
but we deny the call right so at 30
i had the call and i denied it and
i just kept going along as i went along
and then
toward my late 30s my life was not on
the track that i wanted it to be
and i said what's not working
you know i've had these breakups i
you know i get engaged i'm but i don't
follow through
one of my friends called me the runaway
bride right
all the stuff i'm like what is the one
common denominator in all of this
oh that was not the answer i wanted
me right
and all these relationships that i'd had
i was the one common denominator that
wasn't working out
what was going wrong in me and once i
had that
sort of epiphany that the buck stops
with me
and i'm responsible for everything
the way i've manifested my own life you
know that was
everything i saw before me that was a
very sobering moment
now how do i get out of that quicksand
that i had been
consumed by over the years i didn't even
realize i at this point i was so far
under the quicksand i had a straw that
must have gone up like 10 feet to give
me air right
how do i get out of that without sinking
and so
i thought well okay i had a breakup i
was unhappy and
i said i'm going to create a mantra
let's see if this mantra is going to
help me get out of this because i'd
become a total workaholic that was the
other
aspect of my life that i hated i just
worked you know
and traveled for work and i would be on
the road and i'd be in a hotel room and
one day i looked around i was like is
this what i want for my life
it's not what i want i'm lonely out here
i work with people
i have big teams of people and i'm
completely unsatisfied i'm connected
with
no one that's how i felt i mean i have
really i have really good friends but
even them
when you're traveling all the time it's
hard to stay close
so i'd really look at my life and begin
to dissect it but in my personal life i
wanted to get married
but i was telling myself that i wasn't
worthy and somehow when i
really began to dig deep right and so i
created sumatra and i said you know what
if i get married now
or when i'm 90.
it'll be okay or
or never i can't remember it was
something along those lines it's been a
while i've been married
12 and a half years now congratulations
yeah yeah yeah and
um so but i started this mantra because
i could hear the negative voice in my
head and i'm like who is that
like where did she come from and how did
this start
well it didn't really matter but what
mattered was is that i created a new
groove
and that i began to
tell myself it's all going to be okay
if i believe that he's out there looking
for me too
right we'll find each other but i have
to get to a place where
that energetically i'm gonna resonate in
a way
that he can find me we're like beacons
right dude
dude what kind of tone are we sending
out is this beautiful
clear church bell and is that enough and
yes it is
or is it some other kind of fuzzy
half-committed
signal which i was putting out before i
guess what i was finding some other
fuzzy half-committed signal
but when i began to say this is
who i am and what i
want to find in the world he appeared he
appeared really fast within three months
and then there were new things to learn
right so the journey never stops
that's one of the things i'd like to say
about my speakers i have three speakers
right now
one is amy who's a friend um
and you know with everything
that she's been through with the losing
her legs below the knee
um but gone on to live an incredible
life as a snowboarder
she was on dancing with the stars
came in second i mean she's an amazing
woman
i have another speaker that i just
started working with danielle
umstead also on dancing with the star
she's legally blind and she's
a paralympian as well and a blind skier
she can haul down that mountain 70 miles
an hour
i can't do that seeing okay and then i
have another speaker
chris norton who
um had a football injury in college
his freshman year of college and that
injury was
spoiler alert stop the video right now
if you want to look up chris norton and
football
and then watch his talk and learn more
about him
but um he had a neck injury and
is now a quadriplegic you may have seen
some of his videos
um he uh walked for his college
graduation
and he also walked um for his wedding
so those videos have gone viral three
extraordinary people
um that i feel a lot of pressure to help
with their stories and to do justice
with them because
we humans tend to look at story and
think oh that's it i don't know what i
would do
if you know i was blind or i couldn't
you know didn't have feet or i couldn't
walk
unassisted right i was in a wheelchair
uh these people's gone they go on
they've gone on to live rich and full
lives their stories
didn't end there they actually began
there and i think that's a fundamental
difference
um for people who get stuck after an
injury
or after because they'll tell me about
people that they've known where
they're not having the same lives
because they of their beliefs their
deep-seated beliefs that they haven't
worked on changing yet
um they haven't accepted where they are
resistance
is an insidious thing um and so i feel a
lot of pressure
to do right by those stories and to
elevate the stories to say
everybody you know it's not just this
moment that changed the course of their
lives their lives
they continue to have other moments that
are changing the course of their lives
and i think that's important in story
that one moment can be so big that it
can
overshadow the rest but to know that
that you are like these people as you
watch
them in the audience because they think
that they're superheroes the audience
often
and i'm always working and cognizant of
that
to try to elevate that story in a way
that it isn't superhuman that it's human
like you
and you too are superhuman right if that
makes sense
so um i'm i'm very honored to work with
these individuals that are so
exceptional and beautiful